uh our next speaker
is uh well has two atypical passions
they are classical singing and kite
surfing
everyone please welcome colleen
so my name is colleen ceballos i am our
strategy lead in roche pharmaceuticals
since two years
and we'll be
talking about
ensuring the quality of your r packages
for regulatory submissions
a view on how raj enables submissions in
r
this is this title is a bit ambitious i
have to say before we start we don't
fully know yet how to do a clinical
submission to health authorities in r
but i'll share where we are in the uh in
the industry in the pharma industry and
specifically at raj
a couple of words uh before i start uh
because it's probably the first time you
meet me so my name is colleen i'm swiss
and french and i'm based in switzerland
and i'm i think i have a pretty
international background i've lived in
several countries as you can see here
and i'm also married to a bolivian and
u.s
citizen or men so for all of the reasons
you can either speak to me in french
english or spanish but don't try
anything else
my educational background is in business
and i went into the world of data
science and python
a bit later after i started my career
like i like to say that i use my
business and data science and sorry
technical experience um
to lead experts in delivering value
business value so i'm really in between
the technical world and the business
world
um i think it goes without saying that
the
the technical experts are needed in our
industry but we also need people who can
translate our experts work you know for
non-technical people and stakeholders
who usually are also the decision makers
um so that's what i do in my current
position actually right now at r as our
strategy lead in the pharmaceutical
division of roche i drive the i.t
strategy to support the use of open
source programming languages like r and
python and one of my major contributions
recently is around enabling our package
validation in our company
outside of work as jared said i'm into a
extreme sport it's considered extreme
sport uh called kitesurfing so it's a
really cool sport that makes you travel
around the world
uh to find the perfect wind and wave
conditions it's highly i highly
recommend it
so that's it about myself so don't
hesitate to connect with me i'll have my
linkedin and rosh email at the end of
the presentation
so we'll be covering today the following
topics i'll give a little pharmaceutical
context of um
you know because we are going to talk
about uh building package our packages
of quality but i come from the
context so um keep in mind that this is
uh
from coming from one uh
one one lens you know we're looking at
this from one lens we'll talk about the
transition from sas to r and what health
authorities expect
then i'll give you some tips about how
to ensure uh that you build good quality
packages and finally we will
i'll share some
most of the initiatives actually that
rosh is a part of and also not just rosh
but the
pharma industry
what we do basically to enable
submissions in r which is what we are
all interested in today
so the pharma context um
as i said i
i work at rush pharmaceutical
but within pharma i work in i.t to
support the clinical product development
so we see here the the typical
let's say drug development process that
a pharma company needs to follow to
put its drug on the market
in
at rush pharma we are really
that collaboration and open sourcing of
analytical tools is the right way
forward and there's a trend right now to
use more r
um in all the big pharma companies this
is really a unique opportunity to change
the the way we work together and the way
also we um bring new drugs to the
markets
i will share later with you the
different initiatives as i said before
that are ongoing to enable submissions
in r
but we are really at the beginning of
the journey and that's what i was
mentioning to you at the beginning uh in
my first slide is that we are
we just started this journey in actually
in 2019 so two years ago
uh raj t-centrics one of our drugs one
of the working groups of a drug
they completed their first r-based fda
submissions and to our knowledge at the
time it was the first submission within
raj for which the majority of the
analyses were done in r
also it was the first time uh an r
package was submitted to the fda so you
see we come a long way and a couple of
weeks ago actually the news just went
out yesterday
the r consortium which i will i will
talk about later
and raj is an active member of the art
consortium they successfully submitted
an r based test submission package
through the fda
submission portal and the package was
well received by the staff the reviewers
and they were able to reproduce the
numerical results that we obtained so
it's really a great step forward but
just wanted to
remind ourselves that we
are moving
uh
we are at the beginning of our journey
basically i want to say we're moving
slowly but we are moving at the pace we
are moving at which is uh already really
good
if we take a bit of distance from what
we're trying to do in this industry you
know the the general public and
pharmaceutical regulatory agencies
expect medications and medical services
to be the result of a good and sound
science and accurate analyses right so
bugs and defects in the program
used
to analyze this clinical data can result
in incorrect analyses and therefore can
have a damaging consequence
to
public health and trust also right so
it's important for us to follow quality
control processes to identify errors in
our analyses analysis programs
um because we need to remember that
everything we do is for the patient at
the end right there would be no concept
of validation if we didn't have to
deliver
drugs to patients so we have a
responsibility and uh
yeah that's that's first
then from test to r so we come really
from the stats world um
as i said we were just starting to
submit work with r but we come from
everybody using sas
to now
at rush as you can see here we have 45
percent of the current our users who use
r for more than half of their
programming work
so there is a and this was really lower
of course a year or two ago so we are so
we really see in our company and in the
industry a move from sas to r
and i i want to
um remind ourselves that
the the the use of of sas is really not
mandatory so when people ask me can i
submit software programs other than sas
yes so actually the use of s
is not mandatory in the analysis of
clinical study data
so instead other software's like r could
be used the thing with sas is that
we do not need to validate the software
we only need to validate the outputs and
then we archive the programs for future
reference for r in python we need to
also validate the program functionality
and the package system and then we
archive the programs and we need to keep
the package snapshots so that in the
future
if the program is run on the same data
sets health authorities and reviewers
can
obtain the same rules so
we have a new let's say a set of
complexity with open source programming
languages like r compared to sas which
was a licensed and not open source
programming language
um reviewers normally in the in health
authorities they can generally use the
software
that suits their needs of their choice
so we really need to
give an understanding and give them an
understanding of how
our methods work in our analysis so that
they can reproduce
our
our work
but this also means that
the health authorities need to train
themselves to gain the capabilities
for you know receiving running the
programs and the software
that we provide to them so it's not just
us who need in the industry who need to
adapt it's also the health authorities
who need to adapt their internal
capabilities and knowledge
and
also another question i receive is do i
need to follow a particular style
or a convention when i write software
programs
basically a general rule is that
your
your software program needs to be
to be let's say clear and of good
quality regardless of whether you're
going to submit it to health authorities
this is something that we see as big
value that you we develop as
our developers that we develop code
of good quality and there are a lot of
best practice um
guidelines and
guides
available on the internet in several
let's say groups know who
provide their guidance
um
yeah that's really where we come from
right with sas but i just wanted to
break down a myth that sas is the only
programming language
that the fda allows this is not true
so how do we ensure quality of our
packages so i'm going to give you a
couple of
tips
in general
so these are tips to ensure the
reliability and the quality of our
packages used in regulatory interactions
not just for drug approval not not just
for the pharma industry but uh this is
general good good practice so
obviously and some of these mice might
seem obvious for you but they're they're
not really i think so unit tests so you
know this is a primary concern for the
reliability of the package it's really
the
accuracy of the code um
it needs to be
uh
it needs to be
to be let's say covered so unit tests
are basically granular pieces of logic
present in the package that is tested to
ensure that the outputs match
reference values
so
it's it's really important to uh to
specify the unit test to document
to also document statistical methods
implemented um and so on
consider assessing also inputs as part
of a function
this means to consider checks that can
be for example performed on inputs and
where logical
outputs and intermediate values
to minimize the risk
of the package function being used with
inputs that works unexpected by the
developers
peer review seems like a very basic one
but this is really i
advise you to look out for people who
can extend and build on your code
because when a package has significant
use by other uh people and other also
packages in a company's workflow ci cd
testing so continuous integration
content develop deployments testing
should be extended
to also rerun the unit tests against
packages that depend on the developer's
package so really
use use your network to uh
to
build on the go to build your package of
good quality automation is obviously a a
very key point i just mentioned it with
the ci cd
code maturity as well it's also it's
very useful to clearly state the current
maturity of the code particularly to let
people know if the code is still in the
pre-release stage for example
and you can there's one method that you
can use called the lifecycle
you can use lifecycle badges
you know they use this
function lifecycle badge and you write
in parentheses your urants
that's a good small small tip
also refer
refer to the intended use of the package
this is very important it's really a
best practice to
ensure users are aware of the context
the code was written
be to be used in right so you can use
vignettes for example
that's a method to explain the intended
use of the package
and when appropriate the vignettes can
be annotated with notes on the use and
the reference to any relevant literature
that you leverage in the design of your
azure package
another one is uh so in the r language
what is as you as you may know we i'm
sure we have a lot of good
programmers here on the call what is
called our core is composed of base r
and recommended packages
um and the base our pages are developed
and maintained by the our development
core team
and within the r core team development
related
documents guidelines are provided
basically and these guidelines are in
place to maximize code quality and to
facilitate ongoing code validation
during the development of your package
or and in between each version release
so a set of validation tests are
maintained by the our core team to
enable the testing of
code against known data and known
results so any error noted during the
test they are resolved prior to the
release
so this is really handled by the arcore
team for our base package
but
more work is expected on your side when
you're using between quotes maybe
riskier
packages and less widely used package
all right so this is to keep in mind
yeah
double programming as well is one i
don't know if you've heard we use this
term a lot in the pharma industry
basically
this is the idea that
um
you know
the
it's you know we do a double program
analysis
um when we have when we're planning a
regulatory submission in multiple
languages so the quality control step of
analysis programming is a good first use
of open source technologies
and
by using multiple languages basically
any errors or difference in the default
option setting or algorithm that you use
in one programming language can be
taught and
you know and can be identified by uh
double programming by doing it with the
by the other language basically so you
compare the same code
but into the same room let's say yeah
the same code intended code in two
different programming languages
so
what we're doing in this space this is
important to say that to influence
health authorities and for them to
accept to change or to receive something
new or
you know if we have a if for example raj
comes to the fda and says
we would like to submit
our outputs in this format
it's very unlikely that if rosh comes
alone to the fda that the fda will say
okay fine we will adapt all our
processes and and
meet your need
no usually it works more at a sponsor
level at an industry level and the next
three slides will be about those
initiatives at a sponsor level and also
that rosh is a part of obviously
so the art consortium i imagine most of
you have heard about it
our consortium members are probably most
of the big pharmaceutical companies and
biopharma companies
the idea is really to
provide let's say support
in developing maintaining distributing
and
and using
our software um
and they are organized in working groups
i i listed here a couple of working
groups that are of interest in our topic
they're especially the first one which
is the our submission working group
they um focus on i.t and platform
challenges that must be addressed in
order to make an all our regulatory
submission
they provide examples of submission
material
they make it available to the public to
identify potential gaps in our base
submissions so they really work hand in
hand with the fda that's really
important to say because that's the only
way we will move forward it's really to
work with with the fda
and recently this is a key milestone um
so actually i already mentioned it
before but this is really um
their goal is to
allow easier r based
uh clinical trial regulatory submissions
and i i already mentioned the mouse
about it that i wanted to repeat it
then we have another working group which
is the regulatory reporting table
here they create standards to guide the
development of our tools
for creating tables that meet
requirements of the fda so that's also a
very important one then we have our
certification
who
more works on making sure we have
material and curriculum for statistical
programmers have
fields within
that's important then i'll go to reverse
because time is
quickly this is in progress but it's
very promising so i think it's worth
mentioning i cannot share yet a link
but the idea is to
provide
uh open source r packages from like the
whole end to end clinical reporting
packages needed in the end-to-end
workflow that we saw before so really
from
the creation of dtm which is a format we
need to create then from sdtm to adam
which is another format
from then the creation of tlgs the table
listings and graph
and then for to submit
and this is uh for the e-submission
uh process so here we have this is
really a
cross-harmon collaboration we have raj
merck
at least and the other ones i cannot
divulge but this is really really
promising because we will have really a
set of packages that you can use for
your enter
analysis
fuse also accumulates i don't have time
but these are like key initiatives uh
happening cross pharma and here at rosh
we have two
uh pieces that you can choose and reuse
for your validation work that i shared
here
yeah time is passing by i have much more
to say but thank you to the our gov
organizing committee
and of course to all the industry
collaborators
thank you very much